Mr Ren is there anything you want to say on
your own behalf before I pronounce sentence
um so basically I would like to tell the
courts and everyone here like based on my
criminal history like I feel I feel that
like I shouldn't be like sent to prison
for a second time on have you looked at your
criminal history huh have you looked at your
criminal history actually just I looked
at it I mean you lived it I suppose I
just looked at it yeah yeah and you know
three felonies a gross nine misdemeanors
multiple DVS got a lot going on Sir yeah
um I just battery on a protected person
robberies tempt home invasion go ahead I'm me
to interrupt you I was just I I just figure
like I'm I'm in a better place in my mind my my
I have a support system I just got hired as a
te for you know the union you know making $20 an
hour and like the the reason behind every single
domestic violence I've been dealing with mental
health and I didn't know that I was dealing with
mental health and they put me in mental health
court and I still didn't know that I had a
mental health problem until it was August 2022
when I realized I have a problem with this and
like having a dictionary and like understanding
myself getting know myself a little better and
and applying it to my person and and and having
an epiphany at that moment in those instances and
just like trying to learn from my mistakes you
know and I I feel like I shouldn't be sent to
prison but if it's appropriate for you then you
have to do what you have to do but I figure that
know if I'm in a better place in my life I'm
not doing drugs I'm not you know I'm not out
there committing crimes now you know and and I
feel like I should be given a shot because I'm
in a better place than I was then you know so but
that's I'm I'm a person who never stops trying to
do the right thing no matter how hard to get this
and I I just you know and I'm I'm trying and I
never give up trying to do the right thing I'm not
I'm not I know I'm not a rebellious person I'm not
I don't want to be standing here I don't want
you to have to you know sit up there and waste
your time as well you know but the criteria of
me saying this is that I'm a person that never
stops trying to do the right things even if it's
hard and I I did the best I could I I have mental
problems thank you I think the court can trust
that he is going to perform well on probation
I think he's worth this risk the court wants
the 1948 is suggested by by the da I would
have no issue with that but to suspend it rather
than just send him to prison for any the time I
think it makes more sense giv circumstances
and his ability to do probation successfully
give I appreciate that but I think it's
time that he gets a taste of something
else because I just can't with that history
in accordance with the laws of State Nevada
[Music]
this
hey get off her get off her you're
good you're good stop don't do
this Hey where's is she
okay